high priestess the council is waiting
they are perturbed i've wasted our
resources
when they see what i have created here
their wrath will dissipate
it's a new type of birthing part man
that my child
is the next step in our evolution more
powerful more beautiful
more capable of destroying the guardians
of the galaxy
i think i shall call him
adam
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have more exciting news about
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. this
movie already is shaping up to be an
insanely big movie now it is confirmed
to be the final guardians movie in the
franchise which is really sad but that
doesn't mean that we won't see the
guardians pop up in other films and
maybe some of them will even join the
avengers or create a guardians of the
universe team but as for the guardians
of the galaxy actual franchise they have
confirmed this is the last one the last
film so they are going all out the set
is bigger than ever and some insanely
huge characters are about to be
introduced to the mcu like him aka adam
warlock and it has been confirmed that
actor chakuti owuji will be playing a
character in guardians of the galaxy vol
3 as well and will be playing a huge
character now if you followed some of my
videos about guardians 3 you know that a
lot of people including myself believe
that he is going to be playing the high
evolutionary and it just makes sense
based off what him and james gunn have
said that he is going to be playing that
character and today it looks like we
have even more proof and more details
about the character and what is exactly
going to happen with him in guardians 3.
so let's break down what he said in a
recent interview and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos now
what's kind of funny is that chicouti
has actually talked a lot about his
character he just simply hasn't said who
his character is but we can kind of
figure it out and in this interview he
talks about his character being very
different from mirn which is the
character that he plays in the
peacemaker series and he calls his
character an extremist in this interview
here's what he had to say in the
interview when talking about his
character for guardians 3. the
production is so big james and i were
picking up where we left off the
character is very different from mirn
and for those of you who don't know who
mirn is i will describe the character
after this he says it requires different
stuff from me the way james works with
me is pretty much the same which is he
trusts my choices but at the same time
when i give him a choice he's ready to
push it further he's making me push
myself this character needs an extremism
that i didn't need to really tap into in
peacemaker that i'm tapping into here
our relationship remains the same one of
enjoyment mutual love and trust now in
this interview with variety he also goes
on to say that his character will
interact with every single character of
the guardian's team which is kind of
good news but also really bad news it's
good news because it's going to be
really cool to see everybody interact
but bad news because he is most likely
playing the villain who is most likely
the high evolutionary and since this is
the last film of the franchise and the
cast has already talked about how sad
they were reading the scripts this most
likely means that some deaths are
actually coming since he is going to be
interacting with each character now for
those of you who don't know who mirn is
it's a character on the peacemaker
series and james gunn directs that
series as well so chacudi has been
working with james for a while now but
mirn is very timid he's calm most of the
time he's kind of monotone when he
speaks he has some parts where he gets
mad and kind of yells but for the most
part he's a pretty mellow character so
what chikudi is telling us here is that
his character and guardians is the
opposite of him and even says that he
has to go to extreme levels to play this
character he needs a form of extremism
now obviously the opposite of kind of
mellow and calm is really over the top
and high energy and this kind of all
falls into line with the high
evolutionary the high evolutionary is an
extremist his mind is solely focused on
evolution in the beginning of his origin
story he evolved his dog into a creature
that had the intelligence of a
chimpanzee from there on out he would
continue to experiment on animals and
other beings until eventually some of
those animals that he experimented on
became an army for him then he left
earth to start his own earth on a
different planet he literally set out to
make earth 2. now from there a ton
happens and if you want to know what
happens you can watch my video on his
origin story but i've actually linked
him to a few things that we're going to
see in guardians of the galaxy which
kind of confirms that he is the high
evolutionary now who do we know in the
mcu and specifically the guardians
franchise who was set on evolution who
was set on perfection the sovereign they
even said in guardians 2 they don't make
babies the old-fashioned way anymore
women don't birth their babies they
actually make them and then we saw that
in the end adam's cocoon they made adam
warlock so it would make sense that the
high evolutionary is actually the person
in charge of the sovereign this would
require somebody who is an extremist as
chuck woody said also you can imagine
that a character like this is probably
over the top and not very quiet and
pretty outspoken which is the opposite
of mirn the character that chakwoody
plays in peacemaker now also in the
comics the high evolutionary kind of
adopts adam warlock as his son well if
the high evolutionary is in charge of
the sovereign then technically the
sovereign and the high evolutionary are
making adam warlock so he kind of would
be like a son in that perspective and as
far as continuity between all the
guardians of the galaxy film
specifically guardians 2 and 3 goes the
sovereign and another villain are going
to be the main antagonists of this movie
yes adam warlock is going to come into
play yes the sovereign is going to send
adam warlock to destroy the guardians of
the galaxy and perhaps he maybe even
successfully kills one of them but i
think we ultimately know that adam is
not going to be the main villain and
eventually will turn at least somewhat
good by the end of the film that will
leave us with a bigger villain but it
won't get the sovereign off the back of
the guardians of the galaxy they want to
destroy them this is where the person in
charge of the sovereign who i believe to
be the high evolutionary gets really mad
at aisha because in the post credit
scene we already knew that the council
was frustrated with aisha but then the
person in charge takes manners into his
or her hands but again i truly believe
this to be the high evolutionary because
it just all lines up and it'll be
interesting to see how the guardians
line up against adam warlock and then
the sovereign after because the
sovereign actually almost did kill the
guardians in guardians 2. if ego hadn't
have shown up and destroyed all of the
sovereign ships it looks like they would
have been toast they would have all died
which is kind of where adam warlock
comes into play because star-lord
doesn't have his celestial powers
anymore at least that's what we're made
to believe now i kind of think that
they're still there inside of him and
he'll tap into them somehow but for the
time being the guardians don't have a
godlike being with them that is able to
take on the sovereign that's where adam
warlock comes into play that's where he
switches sides and joins them that's
where the power comes from now how will
they be able to take on adam in the
first place not so sure they're
definitely going to have to all fight
together maybe thor comes on board and
he helps them fight him but remember
thor love and thunder takes place before
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so don't
expect thor to be with him so the
guardians are going to have to come up
with some way to beat adam and then
they're all going to have to face who i
believe to be the high evolutionary in
charge of the sovereign but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you